they will talk about interrupts it's
basically a way that your programs can
respond to unexpected events events that
might come in it any ticket for the time
during the program's execution so
someone pushing a key on the keyboard
put the USB stick in a slot a mouse
click code needs to be able to detect
these events and respond to them
interrupts are common ways to do that
straight it on an Arduino because that's
a bit simpler than than using an actual
PC for it so we've got the Arduino Uno
and just a switch an LED and we want to
be able to toggle the LED so it's on
it'll go off and it's off it will go on
the way you might start writing code for
that is you've got your main Arduino
loop if the switch is pressed toggle the
LED that's fairly simple but if you've
got a bunch of other stuff in your
program that say here we've just
simulated and said that other stuff
takes 500 milliseconds to run so you
might be right here load of beta to an
SD card you know be doing a bunch of
complex math or something it takes a lot
of time and that a lot of time means
that sometimes will miss that button
press so excessive relatively slowly it
toggles there's a purse it's fast so
it's unreliable its unreliable yeah it's
only going to pick it up if it happens
to be executing this if switch is
pressed line when someone happens to
press the switch is this a bit like one
of those revolving doors that's always
going around and if you need to get out
the building if you may have got one
sitting it's got to go out the way
you'll get it get it just right this is
called polling you can possibly go out
and poll every single thing in the TV
saying have this happened has this
happen has this happened so instead we
use interrupts and they're basically
special signals that interrupt the
program that's running and the program
execution jumps to a a special routine
interrupt service routine is our and
that basically logs that that event has
happened so that then the operating
system can pick up the event and handle
it appropriately here's the same code so
now we've taken the switch polling out
of the loop so that's just our other
stuff in there and instead in the setup
on this line here we've attached an
interrupt to switch pin so that's going
to across which we want to call this
function switch press is our and the
falling just means we're going to
respond to a particular so only when
it's pressed not when it's released
so can we run that code now and see how
much we're more reliable
clothing so now when I press the button
it's responding every single time I can
do it quite fast so is this always the
way you do this kind of thing that any
events that can happen at an unexpected
time and he was happening really fast
the switch is in marketing trials
actually normally we don't do this
because use a user press which is that's
comparatively slow you can and you can
probably get away with with polling but
for lots of sensors out there they any
digital data that's coming in you simply
can't respond to it fast enough just by
asking what's what state it's in for
example the USB connection here if data
is coming in from your PC it's
ultimately coming into the local
controller byte by byte so you're
getting eight bits in and the hardware
buffer that those bits are stored in
there's probably only another eight bits
coming down the line behind it so you've
got to get in there and store those in
your poke those eight bytes in your
program before they get overwritten so
every time eight bytes comes in as an
interrupt and Arduino does it all in the
background but essentially your program
your sketch execution is halted it jumps
to a specialist special handler that
takes those eight bits out and stalls
them in gram ready so then it's the
buffer is clear for the next matrix to
come in and in any moderately complex
program anything but the simplest
program you simply couldn't do that fast
enough just by buying polling the pin
it's possible but it takes an enormous
amount of program time it takes not
extremely reliable so this idea of every
time something happens that the program
gets interrupted is that how it works
things everything has to stop allow
these computers very very fast these
days but does everything stop just to
sort this out certainly on something
that's got a single core like the
Arduino there's only one thread of
execution yes like exactly what happens
you things stop you go to the interrupt
handler that ones and then your your
main thread of execution resume museum
beyond where you've got multiple core
processes going on and you have more
than one
while of doing things so in a laptop
there will be many many processes we
want and hard drive and one on the USB
harbored all sorts of places and they
will all have probably their own
interrupts and things software going on
in there but at its simplest yes and
into our does exactly how to interrupts
the execution so a a good metaphor might
be you're working at your laptop and
suddenly there's a knock at the door
that interrupts you you have to remember
where you're where you are for your work
you go and answer the door
you handle whatever that is and you come
back and start working again and that's
exactly what the processor has to do it
gets a certain point it has to remember
all the stuff it was doing beforehand so
it fades off various bits of data to
those registers so it can know it where
it has to go back to it runs the
interrupt service routine jumps back to
exactly the same place in execution we
stores all those registers it was before
and then get song as a job so as far as
your program is concerned nothing is
nothing has happened but somewhere
something will have changed so a new
byte will be in a buffer or a slag will
be set somewhere that says hey this
thing has happened you need to deal with
it and interrupts and meant to be fast
and simple and get in and get out
quickly because they've interrupted be
the main thread of execution because
you're already in the interrupts so if
you can't interrupt an interruption run
no yeah some processors will allow for
them to called reentrant interrupts
where you where you can advance them
interrupts but generally you don't want
to go down that road because it leads